qu'il y a Mbappe de presse avec l'équipe
de France alors qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
qu'il a peur remis les pendules à
l'heure alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que Kylian Mbappe est en contrat avec le
PSG jusqu'en juin 2024 et à partir de ce
moment il repartirait libre ce qui
empêcherait le les joueurs enfin les
dirigeants du paysage d'ici cet été et
donc de gagner de l'argent sur son dos
leur envoyer une lettre en disant qu'il
souhaitait prolonger son contrat
jusqu'en juin 2024 et partir libre ce
qui a beaucoup offusqué les dirigeants
du PSG et en marche du salon vivatech
hier Emmanuel Macron comme d'habitude
c'est initié là-dedans et a dit voilà
qu'il essayerait en répondant à fan qui
lui demandait si tu étais au courant du
départ de Kylian il lui a dit il lui a
dit bah je vais tout faire pour le
pousser et ce qui est drôle c'est que
c'est que Kylian Mbappe a répondu en
conférence de presse à l'instant que que
quand on lui a posé la question de
savoir si le président avait une
influence sa carrière il a répondu
aucune envoie un peu l'amour
c'est sûr
un enfant m'interpelle me dit est-ce que
tu est-ce que Raymond va rester je lui
dis oui j'ai tout faire pour bien
entendu
faire plaisir à l'enfant je vais te dire
là le PSG c'est une histoire de grossou
je vous le dis c'est à dire que ou qu'il
y a et je comprends là Killian Mbappe il
a un dilemme incroyable devant lui c'est
où il se dit je vais faire toute ma
carrière au PSG pratiquement bah oui
parce que là il a 25 ans il va faire 25
ans là ça veut dire que si rossignent
encore trois quatre ans il va faire
voilà il va finir sa carrière au PSG
est-ce qu'il va gagner un ballon d'or ce
qui va gagner les Ligues des Champions
ou bien j'arrête en 2024 et je pars
peut-être au Real Madrid voyant club
dans son club réveil en plus il y a
Karim Benzema est parti donc on peut
attaquants de pointe
et derrière tu as le PSG toi et moi je
comprends tout à fait le PSG et je vais
vous dire mes amis et mon ami
jamais caché ici c'est Nasser voilà
c'est mon ami voilà je je l'adore et
c'est un type extraordinaire et lui bah
lui bah si moi j'ai fait monter Killian
Mbappe c'est mine de rien j'ai fait de
lui quand même la star que c'est qui
vient de Mbappé il a il a beaucoup
rapporté au PSG aussi 5 joueurs
incroyable mais bon je peux pas ne rien
gagner sur le Paris-Saint-Germain sur
quotidien Mbappé donc où je le laisse
partir cette année cet été et je prends
180 200 millions et là bon en ce qui
tombe et je reconstruis une équipe moi
je veux dire je vais donner un exemple
moi mon père il adoré l'OM quand papa
est parti de l'OM c'était en 93 je crois
il m'a dit c'est une catastrophe et bien
l'OM a gagné la Ligue des Champions
quand papa est parti il a été au Milan
AC il est en finale contre il était pas
titulaire un Jean-Pierre Papin le Shadow
aussi et ils ont été champion d'Europe à
un moment après moi je te conseille de
la personne mais à un moment le club
doit appartenir au propriétaire
et non pas aux joueurs un moment voilà
c'est un moment c'est tu peux pas un
moment si un joueur et c'est normal et
il y a même pas que c'est une telle star
c'est un tel joueur que aujourd'hui
c'est ça c'est que le club après ta
partie en plus et si tu laisses passer
tu laisses tout passer un moment le club
il t'appartient pas et le PSG
aujourd'hui je me demande moi c'est le
PSG n'a pas intérêt à construire sans
qu'il y a Mbappé ils ont pas gagné la
Ligue des Champions avec lui ils peuvent
très bien la gagner sans lui il y a des
très bons joueurs on repart d'une
feuille blanche on a 200 millions et là
je peux vous dire qu'on peut acheter des
joueurs et au moins Killian est content
parce que c'est son rêve moi je vais
vous dire que c'est son rêve moi moi
j'ai parfois je le vois Paris je le sens
je le sens je le sens triste je vous
jure que c'est vrai je le sens triste
des fois quand ils jouent sur la fin de
la saison j'ai senti triste un moment
c'est que c'est comme avec une femme si
tu es pas heureux bah maman
moi je crois qu'il faut jamais retenir
un joueur contre son gré c'est comme un
animateur un chroniqueur c'est vrai
c'est un moment si tu viens pas avec le
sourire si tu viens pas c'est vrai si tu
kiffes pas il faut que tu
avoir de la reconnaissance sauf que là
les 200.000 abonnés les 200 millions
dont on parle ça va potentiellement
arriver dans sa poche s'il reste un an
qu'il rentre
signature 180 c'est pour lui pour le
faire Paris Saint-Germain c'est quand
même un dilemme c'est c'est tout pour
l'oseille en fait c'est ça qui est chaud
voilà le club lui reproche Cyril on peut
pas avoir prolongé le vélo l'option
jusqu'en 2025 exactement
on comprend aussi voilà on est tous des
businessman Killian il se dit voilà moi
je finis l'année prochaine au PSG je
suis libre au lieu de donner 200
millions de PSG vous m'en donnez à la
prime à la signature 150 à moi vous
faites le Real Madrid fait une économie
de 50 millions moi je prends directement
les 150 millions et en plus j'ai mon
salaire Montréal donc on prend mais à un
moment voilà tout le monde est content
tu signes jusqu'au prolonge d'un empêché
tu parles l'année prochaine pêche le PSG
prend les 200 millions tu fais une
saison de plus tout le monde est content
et voilà non mais d'autant plus que le
Real n'a pas les moyens du PSG donc il
aura pas un salaire comme il a en
Killian va baisser son salaire pour
aller il avait intérêt aussi à 750
moi je pense moi je pense que ça va
s'arranger oui c'est un bras de fer je
suis sûr mais en tout cas il faut que le
PSG garde la main sur le club les
supporters du PSG n'en voudront jamais
au PSG voilà c'est ils n'ont pas gagné
avec lui donc peut-être qu'il gagneront
voilà aujourd'hui et je le dis moi tous
les gens qui critiquent aussi le PSG les
mecs Manchester City vous avez mis
combien vous avez vu combien de temps
ils ont mis à gagner la Ligue des
Champions quand moi 11 ans exactement
aujourd'hui quand je vois ce qui a fait
la série ce qu'on fait les dirigeants
Catari sur le PSG les mecs quand qui
nous auraient dit il y a 10 ans que
quand tu as péréal ou PSG - Bayern dans
ta tête c'est le PSG qui doit gagner et
c'est le PSG qui est favori rien qu'avec
ça c'est déjà énorme voilà je le dis
parce que voilà c'est quand même énorme
et je le sais je suis sûr qu'ils vont
finir par la gagner avec des champions
c'est comme Manchester City ça prend du
temps mais à un moment quand tu as un
mec qui prend un moment il faut que tu
construis son équipe c'est une équipe un
moment un moment parfois il faut dire
moi je veux dire je vous jure que c'est
vrai que j'ai eu des chroniqueurs
parfois ici moi je vous dis j'ai eu des
chroniqueurs très forts qui voulait
venir et aussi fort que vous mais
vraiment et j'ai eu un mec à un moment
qui vous dit je voudrais pas son nom qui
était vraiment très très fort et je me
suis dit il est très bon mais il va tuer
le collectif je vous jure que c'est vrai
je pense que les les autres chroniqueurs
vont être inhibés et comme voilà ça va
beaucoup tout ça j'ai peur que il soit
pas bon les chroniqueurs et qui casse la
main un moment voilà un moment faut que
tu il faut que tu fasses une équipe je
vous jure que c'est vrai voilà et c'est
vrai que là voilà vous vous êtes
l'équipe parfaite et puis en plus vous
avez signé rien du tout
donc c'est important